trois chambres meublées tout juste
rénové cet appartement et deux autres
dans le même immeuble sont prêts à être
loués 150 euros par mois mais
exclusivement pour les étudiants en
médecine en stage dans le département
très souvent ils viennent pour une durée
déterminée c'est parfois courtes
mi-semaine six mois c'est compliqué
parce que c'est quand même des gens qui
payent un loyer à clermont et dijon donc
qu'ils sont dans l'obligation de se
loger et on pense que sa faveur ça va
favoriser la venue de ces étudiants en
médecine
un dispositif qui s'ajoute à d'autres
lancés ces dernières années jamie
lavallois est actuellement en stage à
nevers depuis un an et demi elle touche
500 euros par mois du département une
bourse qui l'a décidé à franchir le pas
j'avais un prospectus à l'internât donc
je suis tombé dessus par hasard et j'ai
vu qu'ils offraient une bourse aux
étudiants en médecins
donc pour ceux qui désirent s installer
dans la nièvre moi je suis originaire de
petits champs à la base donc je n'étais
pas du tout fait à l'idée d'aller dans
la nièvre
au final c'est un mal pour un bien car
ce sont ces incitations la nièvre n'est
pas la destination privilégiée par les
étudiants dijonnais la distance et
l'accessibilité décourage de nombreux
externe
il ya des certains stages où
effectivement
on tourne à vide et donc on optimise pas
le nombre de maîtres de stage qu'on peut
avoir
l'enjeu c'est donc de leur simplifier la
vie est de changer l'image qui a parfois
le département à la faculté de médecine
on leur montre qu'il ya des tas de
choses à faire dans le département pour
leur donner envie de revenir qui tirent
leur stage d'un terne dans le
département et ensuite qu'ils créent
leur réseau sur place et une fois qu'ils
ont créé leur réseau sur place on peut
espérer qu'ils s'y installer qu'ils y
restent et les premiers signes laissent
de l'espoir
depuis trois ans 22 contrats de bourse
ont été signés et trois jeunes médecins
se sont déjà installés à nevers